so this this is this is the this is the
big issue man
if you don't have access to technology
how can you
uh how can you actually win so you think
if someone
attempts a violent uprising that the
tech companies would be in
cahoots with like the government and
shut them out like cut off their isps
cut out their communication tactics
it's it's hard to say what what what
what's the allegiance of these
corporations right no that's really
they're very ideological corporate it's
just their allegiances to their business
plan
maybe but they're but we've we've seen
them overtly like
i i think i think they're willing to
sacrifice business in exchange for
ideological gains
some of them i twitter especially yeah
like twitter twitter
you know some people have argued why is
it that they allow antifa to stay on the
platform there's actually a really
really good answer
you know why so the cops know what their
plans are good good point
otherwise they'll be in the shadows
they're not concerned about stuart
rhodes
saying you know think whatever so
there's so twitter's just like get rid
of them
and then you have all these antivirus
saying here we're going to go do this
this thing at this place
and then you probably have the cops
saying please don't ban them they're
giving us their intel
oh wow maybe yeah yep it's impossible to
know that's crazy
but so so the main the main point though
uh is
would twitter side with the far left in
the event of
some kind of civil war and it's like the
answer is yes whip of a coin man
who runs twitter we don't even know oh
it's over it's over
stockholders yeah it's it's so so here's
here's my prediction because i've had
this conversation with people i'm like
listen
let's say that's on november right now
twitter and facebook have both said
if donald trump tries to declare victory
in the election they'll remove his his
posts this is after the votes come in
yeah yeah oh wow if on november 4th
it is a trump landslide with no possible
way for biden to win
and trump says we did it i won there's
no way the mailing votes will get it
they said if trump tries to declare
victory early
we will remove those posts twitter and
facebook said that just trump not biden
just trump do you think they were
insinuating that anyone that does it
would be removed
but that's the dumb question because
they didn't they just said trump right
so so here's what happens november
november uh
4th landslide trump 400 electoral votes
no way biden can win trump comes out and
he has a press conference and says
even if the mailing votes come in no one
expects you know
the experts are saying and you'll get
like a bunch of conservative outlets
saying there's no way you could possibly
flip these to biden even with mail-in
votes based on you know traditional
voter
like turnout and stuff like this then
biden refuses to concede like hillary
clinton asks
hillary clinton straight up said biden
should not concede so he goes i am not
going to concede because we are going to
count these votes to the very end
trump says there's no way you can win
i'm the victor a week goes by and all of
a sudden
record voter turnout who'd have thought
and they found a bunch of ballots just
stacked in the back of a post office
well convenient for them and then biden
squeaks by
with just enough electoral votes for a
narrow very narrow victory
and then biden comes out and says you
see we've won and then trump says this
is not
possible and then you have two two
factions declaring victory
trump then says we're gonna sue we're
gonna sue they say well we're gonna sue
you back no one knows what happens
and then you end up with a circumstance
where you now have trump being declaring
himself victor biden declaring himself
victor what do you think happens in
scenario that would be like uh instance
of
a potential civil war when you have two
leaders nope that are
at it nope what would you think would
happen nope nope new york times
washington post the wall street journal
time magazine printing biden's the
victory is the victor
yeah done and then just try and just
move if you tell someone a lie enough
times they start to believe it
and then what happens when trump when
i'll
put it this way what would happen if
trump does win and it's
and because they won't give us the
results right away trump wins you know
400 whatever electoral votes
then uh trump says i won there's no way
they can win and then all of a sudden
all the media companies just announced
biden one
that would be like not treason i mean i
don't want to use that word
but what if what if
you know someone from the clinton from
the democratic campaign or like uh i was
gonna say podesta who was
clinton's campaign manager they go and
they say here's the proof here's the
documents
we won and then the new york times all
these mainstream outlets say
you know uh uh election commission
reports that we've reviewed
show that joe biden is in fact the
winner even though the official election
results reported to the federal
government
would show trump the winner in fact joe
biden won right so now you've got the
media telling everyone no no look we
went over the numbers it's true joe
biden won
and trump starts saying i won then
twitter bans trump
then you've got a bunch of uh a bunch of
people actually within the government
right
let's say a bunch of secret service
people and a bunch of uh feds
know for a fact it's certified a trump
victory but the media's reporting
otherwise
so they they they go with trump they
don't worry mr president we're gonna get
a hold of things and they start rushing
to the white house or whatever
and then all of a sudden a bunch of
national guardsmen
have their phones going remember and
they all see this donald trump is trying
to stay jakku
new york times washington post trump is
trying to steal steal the white house
what will they believe and then their
commanding officer is sitting there
saying
i don't know yeah who won that's
drastically confusing who won
trump is still president right until the
fourth no matter what until january of
something or until
next time so if there's a contention
he's still president
right so that's why i think that
scenario is
what can you do uh make him reveal their
code or something
he can't do that i don't know what he
would do but he i think he would i'm not
trying to rest
to be honest i don't know i'm not saying
that scenario will happen i'm trying to
make a point about what happens
confusion
if yeah if if there comes a point where
joe biden and donald trump are both
standing there
and they both point to the secret
service and they go arrest that man
hopefully the secret service won't do
anything the secret service are gonna
look at their phone and they're gonna
see all the mainstream media saying joe
biden won
yeah but they're supposed to be trump's
bodyguard so or the president
what i mean to say is the media is on
the side of the left
and so is social media and if trump
can't communicate and trump supporters
can't communicate
then then regular people are going to
see trump as the bad guy because the
media will say so
that that's probably kind of what's
happening already exactly exactly
um so the vote's coming in and it's
going to be confusing there's going to
be mail and votes right it's decided
we're doing mail-in votes
in many states not everything so it's
going to be give it two weeks after
the uh the fourth before you start
deciding who won because they're going
to have to count all the
stuff it's going to take weeks i got to
tell you man i'm really excited for
november 4th till january 19th that's
gonna be awesome you know why
because it's just no no i think it's
look it's a rainfall what are you going
on
there's going to be a lot of bad things
a windfall there's gonna be a lot of bad
things
but if trump loses i'm actually really
looking forward to that you know why
why could you imagine what that guy's
gonna do when he knows like
go on rogan first immediately which you
should do anyway
i lost it's fine telling everybody
here's here's a book of all the pardons
oh that'd be awesome everyone yeah and
what have you pardoned everybody
i literally could do that anyway win or
lose he could just go on a partnership
and he well i think he should pardon a
lot of people that'd be great that'd be
great optics
for him and for his family whether he
whether he wins or loses
even if he doesn't know it's going to be
like january 19th he's going to be like
well i guess nancy pelosi is president
no one has any idea
who won the election i'm just going to
pardon everybody dude this goes for it
and he's like
dude
just goes nuts so there's actually an
article that came out today where they
were panicking about it
and it was like it was like what is it
called like the 78 days of destruction
or something
it was like yeah the day the day after
the election until the 20th yeah
trump is going to unleash fury there was
a picture of trump like looking als
like grim and there's like fire behind
him and then yeah and then and like
america is floating above the fire
oh they're creating i'm like i don't
know about all that but trump will
probably
order with a withdrawal of all the
troops and it'll jam up the courts
they'll go to the courts
and they'll try and block him and he
does a bunch of things but he i think
he's gonna
he i i i man i i want to believe
could you imagine if he was like flint
water crisis
allocate federal resources solve that
problem snowden assange
pardoned soldiers in the middle east
withdraw everybody just legalize
marijuana
everybody yep yep executive order
offenders well he can't legalize it but
he can put an executive order ordering
them
off schedule one not to enforce oh great
congress would have to do
the scheduling i think but he can say no
longer enforce marijuana laws
de facto uh uh de facto legalization but
then he could also say
non-violent offenders yeah free to go
pardon all
so anything he was gonna do in his
second term he'll do
in those days just have to force him to
do it in a few months and
give him some time because i think he's
going to figure out new stuff to do as
time goes on
yeah of course as president who knows
what's going to happen i think
uh there's always a lot of developments
and
the interesting thing right now is that
although they keep saying joe biden is
favored to win
the polls are in his favor sure nate
silver tweeted
that the only safe bet for biden is if
he wins five
points more than trump of the national
popular vote
then he's safe what does that mean
exactly so if joe biden gets
45 and trump gets 40. okay that's
percent
yeah or if joe biden gets 49 and trump
gets you know 44.
but if joe biden gets 47 and trump gets
46 or
what was that what was the percentages
last time it was like the 40s like 42
yeah i would say 40 to 40 yeah so so
like trump got 40.
if tru if it's within two points trump
has a 78 chance of winning
why is that because electoral college
favors him oh cool we're all states
yeah they jammed too many people up in
california you know mm-hmm but that's
weird
yeah yeah so when you look at the
electoral college
i don't think joe biden's going to get a
five-point lead on trump
i don't know much about the the uh like
how it's built that how that system
works
unfortunately so the general ideas and
the national popular vote doesn't matter
because california and new york are so
populous of course the democrats will
win
the national popular vote okay but when
you factor in the electoral college
because the president
has chosen chosen based on states then
trump is favored because more more
states are willing to support them
so it's hard to know man there's been a
lot of there's been a lot of changes in
the polls
but if i look at the polls now i look at
joe biden's character
there's a there's a lot of reasons to
believe that joe biden's absolutely
gonna lose
i know but there's reason to believe
he's gonna win well it wouldn't be a
biden victory it'd be a trump loss
exactly yeah right right
right right the media is smearing trump
they're not pushing biden at all because
there's nothing positive
barely anything positive about that guy
to show oh he talks and makes
mistakes with his words which is
hilarious
did you do that did you see the uh the
the guy from the biden campaign was
asked by bret baer does body is a
teleprompter
and the dude just was like right that's
a trump talking point
i am not gonna allow trump to filter
questions through fox news
and brett was like so you can't answer
yes or no does he use a teleprompter
of course body uses a teleprompter
here's what people don't get about biden
let me clarify some things for you
people say he's a gaff machine right oh
yeah he always has been he he is a gaff
machine but what people don't realize
about a lot of his gaffes
is that the prompter stopped moving it's
that simple and he has no
and so there was one point where he said
his wife what did he what did he say
about like he repeated her name
yeah like um my wife wife my wife
my wife yeah yeah so it's something was
wrong with his teleprompter for sure
exactly stuttering
or something no it stopped yeah and it
was stopped on his on
right right he said something like this
is jill my wife
my wife my wife my wife and people are
like
what's he doing oh my god because the
prompter stopped
dude and then he was like my wife
there's actually 90s he plagiarized and
got like
made fun of he played your eyes this
speech last week or whatever yeah
the canadian guy this is insanity yeah
joe biden
just give it i mean no vote that's the
way it works you know just give it to
somebody
but let's just kind of work on tech
other technologies together
here's one of my bigger concerns about
everything uh so the democrats blocked
the covid relief package
how's that work so uh they needed 60
votes in the senate to get it passed
and it's not it's 50 it's like 52
republicans or whatever so it was
partisan lines
and the democrats in their bill they
wanted to ban voter id
why yeah that's like make secure make
make elections less secure
do people not have ids is that is that a
common thing no are there citizens
no i mean mine's expired i'm in the
process of getting a new one
really some people don't have ideas but
no i still have an idea of my passport i
mean right you kind of got to have an id
yeah exactly to be a functioning person
so
i feel like what we're seeing with this
with blocking this bill the democrats
wanted to change a bunch of election
rules they wanted to change voter voter
uh signature verification rules to give
people a chance to correct them which
could draw out the election
the republicans said no the republicans
offered up coveted relief the democrats
said no and it's just purely tribal
lines
purely tribal this two-party system is
gone it's gonna collapse
because it's not about do we need
coveted relief no it's don't let the
republicans win
that's craziness right and they want to
tag things into it like a voter
registration law to a coveted relief
yeah yeah that weird well to be fair the
republicans putting everybody in fbi fbi
uh building and like new abrams missiles
or whatever has that been legal since
the beginning of the country
i think so it's just like what do you do
you can't add something else to a bill
but how do you determine what is or
like you could argue
how do you how do you define the terms
you know i don't know i don't know good
point like is it in the same
genre of what you're voting on is it is
it related to coveted relief if not then
no it can't be part of this package
well they can argue well as part of
covert relief we need a strong federal
apparatus to enforce the rules around
kovis so they talk
it's a big talking game about talking
it's a debate
convince them of nonsense i'll tell you
what but i'll tell you what
if if people in the government are like
we're gonna provide covet relief
and build tanks i'd be like yeah what
else is new give me the code of relief
if the democrats are like we're gonna
give you covet relief three times higher
the republicans
and weaken all of our election you know
processes i'd be like whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
what are they called ear marks yes
random
i'll sponsor this but i get a boat we
got a congressional boat 90 page bills
that
i don't think they they like hire
lawyers to write for them and then they
don't even have to read it before they
vote on it
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you